qu'est ce que je me dis moi oui il ya
toujours pire ailleurs il ya des pays où
c'est légal de licenciés par texto tu
savais pas mais c'est là que notre plan
de départs volontaires il est
progressiste
il faut saisir l'opportunité c'est une
offre premium ce départ ce que dans six
mois on sait pas ce qui restera que des
miettes on sera obligés de se
délocaliser dans dans les pays de l'est
tu comprends pas d'accord du coup qui
sait que vous verrez et non tu comprends
pas tuer l'élue
celui qui va prendre pour tous les
autres maintenant il faut juste que je
m'arrange pour que tu comptais dizaines
de toits takka takka takka takka takka
takka sa mère regarde moi non mais ya
que des bons dossiers dans ce bureau
c'est sublime
non mais tu te fais pas chier à temps
plein stage transformer non mais pas du
tout madame venez à mon bureau s'il vous
plaît je désirerais vous évaluez pensez
vous tu t'inquiètes à catane retournez
vous sur vous même à quatre pattes
j'ai pas du tout mais on est tous pareil
tout ça ferait la même chose à ta place
tu serres où un homme je rentre dans son
jeu pour réussir à l'autre qu'on vende
enfin c'est vrai je ne vais pas dire le
contraire il y à des femmes
qui sont bonnes non au ça marche
j'ai pénétré la psychologie du mal de
base c'est quoi ton problème à mon
problème il est dans mon pantalon
bon je vais un conseil c'est ça hein
j'ai compris tu veux la vie vu de
l'intérieur
non moi je peux te dégager qui tu veux
tu as un trombinoscope son temps dit on
ne le rachète embête pas dans ça
sûrement ça ça me fait plaisir
vraiment vas-y agen de justin sur ces
deux questions c'est normal cette
situation qu'est ce qui fait que la
boîte ne marche pas c'est qu'il ya plein
point mort je jure j'ai l'impression
d'être un guépard au milieu des
escargots
je tire tout le monde vers le haut et je
m'épuise a fait voir de trombinoscope
maintenant comment il a réussi à
retourner la situation pour que j'arrive
pas à faire ça moi me domine qu'un
départ moi je suis un épagneul breton
voila voila ca trombinoscope attend mais
qu'est ce qui me fait là alors amputé
escargots lui c'est nul
escargots et c'est monstrueux mais c'est
pas possible vraiment débile alors on
est vraiment sur quelque chose
oui ça c'est un mâle alpha et moi je
suis quoi indien coi après alpha beta de
gama je suis un de mal gamme a
énormément de boulet de canon
hollande a tendance à trop prenant si ce
rapprochement quand je viendrai flat
beat alice non non non là c'est ma
copine ne touche pas mal tu peux la
dégager les yeux fermés elle ne sert à
rien mais ça c'est inégal
non non alice alice dont il faut juste
quelque chose merde beaucoup de
compétences il c'est une beauté
[Musique]
mais ça va ça fait pas mal
en attendant la perche vélo bhv spin off
et donc tu es une augmentation ben oui
s'il y en a bien un qui la mérite ici
c'est bien peu de sens là
[Musique]